[Música]
los cinco ex policías Implicados En la
muerte del afro estadounidense tabern
Nichols se declararon no culpables
durante la audiencia de presentación de
cargos un tribunal de la ciudad de
Memphis los acusa entre otras cosas de
asesinato en segundo grado los padres de
Nichols declararon que lucharán hasta
que obtengan justicia
la privación arbitraria de la
nacionalidad en Nicaragua va en contra
del derecho internacional así lo ha
denunciado la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados acnur refiriéndose al caso de
los más de 300 opositores nicaragüenses
que fueron desterrados por el régimen
autoritario de Daniela Ortega
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador anunció que rechaza pasar
el mando de la alianza del Pacífico a
Perú amlo afirmó que someterá la
decisión a consulta ante los miembros
del grupo de Río y que aceptará su
decisión ampliamos desde Ciudad de
México
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos en Estados Unidos los cinco
ex policías Implicados En la muerte de
la afroamericano tayor Nichols se
declararon no culpables un tribunal de
Memphis los acusa entre otros cargos de
asesinato en segundo grado agresión
agravada y secuestro agravado el caso
dio la vuelta a todo el país luego que
la fiscalía publicara un vídeo en el que
se veía como los oficiales golpearon al
joven durante varios minutos los padres
de Nichols declararon que seguirán en el
proceso hasta que obtengan justicia
todos se declararon inocentes son los
policías que golpearon hasta la muerte
al joven de 29 años tyrie Nichols
actualmente los ex agentes están en
Libertad bajo fianza negaron su
culpabilidad ante los cargos de
asesinato en segundo grado asalto y
secuestro agravados y opresión oficial
en la parte trasera de la sala estaba la
familia de Nichols quien a su vez era
padre de un niño de 4 años
sé que mi hijo se ha ido sé que nunca lo
volvería a ver
pero tenemos que empezar este proceso de
Justicia ahora mismo
y quiero que todos y cada uno de esos
policías puedan mirarme a la cara
todavía no han hecho eso
ni siquiera pudieron hacer eso hoy ni
siquiera tuvieron el coraje de mirarme a
la cara después de lo que le hicieron a
mi hijo
entonces me van a ver en cada cita en la
corte en cada una hasta que obtengamos
justicia para mi hijo
estoy aquí para asegurarme de que haya
justicia para nuestro hijo es un día
glorioso es el inicio del proceso
los ex policías deberán comparecer
nuevamente ante la justicia el primero
de mayo
eso fue muy emotivo y hubo muchas cosas
que no se dijeron en la sala del
tribunal hoy en el proceso
pero fue un día muy informativo a medida
que nos acercamos a la justicia
los acusados golpearon a nicoles tras un
control de tránsito sobre el que no está
Clara la causa de la detención tras ello
tuvo que ser hospitalizado y murió pocos
días después los cinco agentes fueron
despedidos tras una investigación
interna del pasado 26 de enero ante el
temor de una ola de rechazo a lo
sucedido similar a la que siguió a la
muerte de George Floyd en 2020 la
policía local también anunció la
disolución del escuadrón escorpión del
que formaban parte de los cuatro agentes
seguimos en Estados Unidos porque se
cumplen dos semanas del descarrilamiento
de un tren que transportaba material
tóxico en Ohio la administración de Joe
biden defendió este viernes su respuesta
ante esta situación que afecta a un
pueblo de 5000 habitantes el gobernador
también insistió en rebajar la
preocupación mientras que desde la
comunidad continúan denunciando
afectaciones a la salud Juan pupiales
tiene los detalles
Bienvenidos a Easy palestin una
localidad pequeña que hoy por hoy vive
una crisis sanitaria que Escala niveles
nacionales hace ya dos semanas que un
tren descarriló en este pueblo de unos
4.700 habitantes 10 de los vagones que
se volcaron portaban material tóxico
Ted Murphy es un vecino que exhibe como
luce el agua de la zona llegó hace 7
meses pero dice que ya debe volver a
hacer las maletas trabajé hasta el
cansancio para que este lugar luzca como
lo hace y ahora debo mudarme porque no
estoy seguro aquí
para otros vecinos la preocupación no
solo es el agua sino los dolores de
cabeza o la irritación en los ojos que
han empezado a sufrir
esto es peor a lo que cualquiera pensaba
la gente en el pueblo tiene miedo tienen
miedo yo tengo miedo
desde el gobierno Estatal informaron
este viernes que los monitoreos sobre la
calidad del aire y del agua del
Acueducto de hispalesting arrojaron
resultados positivos y no hay razones
para preocuparse incluso desde la propia
casa blanca defendieron su estrategia en
medio de unas críticas que aparecen ya
en el mismo congreso estamos
comprometidos con apoyar al pueblo de
ispalestin en cada paso del camino vamos
a estar en el terreno ayudándoles todo
el tiempo que sea necesario de momento
la presencia sobre el terreno de un alto
funcionario del gobierno se reduce a la
de Michael Reagan director de la agencia
de protección ambiental el estado de
Ohio anunció que desde la otra semana
abrirá una clínica para atender a
quienes presenten síntomas además El
Ejecutivo Federal enviará médicos y
toxicólogos para colaborar en las
labores de recolección y examen de
muestras
el destierro y la privación de
nacionalidad a más de 300 opositores
nicaragüenses dictados por el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega sigue provocando
reacciones este viernes la agencia de la
ONU para los refugiados acnur denunció
que esta actuación vía la viola las
leyes internacionales el organismo
recordó que el derecho internacional
la privación arbitraria de nacionalidad
sobre bases políticas religiosas
raciales o étnicas en Nicaragua las
reformas legislativas más recientes que
permiten privar arbitrariamente a una
persona de la ciudadanía contraviene en
las obligaciones que tiene este país en
el marco del derecho internacional y
Regional de los Derechos Humanos el
derecho internacional prohíbe la
privación arbitraria de la nacionalidad
por motivos raciales étnicos religiosos
o políticos De igual forma privar a
alguien de su nacionalidad nunca se
justificará por el ejercicio de derechos
fundamentales como la libertad de
expresión la libertad de asociación u
otros derechos relacionados con las
opiniones políticas de una persona nos
vamos ahora a México porque el
presidente del país Andrés Manuel López
Obrador anunció que rechaza pasar el
mando de la alianza del Pacífico a Perú
sin embargo aseguró que no es una
negación rotunda sino que consultará a
los miembros del grupo de ríos sobre Qué
pasó dar y aceptará su decisión
anteriormente nuestro González en Ciudad
de México Mario carbonell nos contaba
Cuáles han sido las razones detrás de
este anuncio de López Obrador y qué
repercusiones han tenido en la política
mexicana
Pues el presidente argumenta que
considera al gobierno actual de Perú
como espurio dice que entregarle la
presidencia de la alianza sería
legitimar un golpe de estado que él
asegura es contrario a las libertades a
los derechos humanos y es
antidemocrático es Por ello que dijo no
está dispuesto o no quiere por lo menos
ahora entregar la presidencia
hay algunas reacciones ya en el sector
político en México sobre todo el partido
Acción Nacional de oposición ha fijado
una postura para criticar este esta este
posicionamiento de López Obrador y
señalar que está marcado por su
ideología en temas de política exterior
dice que busca apoyar a sus amigos
autoritarios de la región En referencia
Pedro castillo y también considera que
no puede López Obrador tomar una
decisión de esta naturaleza de manera
unilateral esta postura se suma a la que
ya se había dado en días previos por
parte de senadores del mismo partido
Acción Nacional pero también de otros
partidos del Pri incluso del grupo
plural como Emilio Álvarez icaza Beatriz
paredes Gina Cruz que han cuestionado
que López Obrador Por una parte busque
intervenir en Perú Pero por otra parte
calle no diga nada de la situación de
Derechos Humanos que está viviendo Por
ejemplo Nicaragua Así un poco las
reacciones hasta ahora en torno de esta
decisión de López Obrador consultada por
Franz 24 la internacionalista Erika Ruiz
considera que no es viable que los
países que integran lo que fuera el
grupo de Río tomen una postura ahora a
ese respecto
cerramos este informativo con el famoso
carnaval de Río de Janeiro que comenzó
este viernes por primera vez sin
restricciones Desde que comenzará la
pandemia de Kobe 19 las celebraciones
iniciaron con la ceremonia de entrega
del control de la ciudad al rey momo más
adelante en el día por filas comparsas
llenaron el sambódromo de río con las
gradas llenas de espectadores se espera
que unos 46 millones de personas se unan
a esta fiesta que acabará oficialmente
el 22 de febrero
con estas imágenes desde Río de Janeiro
Nos despedimos sigan con nosotros
[Música]